thank you all for coming I guess you
haven't gotten tired of me yet but we'll
see if anybody shows up next week so
nice to see so many great friends here
tonight and I think it should be a lot
of fun like there's a lot of cool stuff
that I want to try to show you tonight
so first I got to see if technologies
whoa you got this so as Pak said the the
title is is is I can learn how to zoom
in here okay here we go yeah stick tight
pie in the up whoops whoops wrong title
pie in the art of computer programming
coffee so the art of computer
programming is this book that I started
to write in 1962 and and and by now
we're like what I wanted to show you
today was that clean this zoom the other
way ago this is supposedly in book
stores maybe tomorrow
and I was hooking I was hoping I would
get my first copy today that this is not
a real copy this is what they call a a
galley I think it's the only galley in
existence so that at the moment it's the
only copy of of volume four fascicle
five that exists but it can you really
get mathematical introduction of
backtracking and dancing links dancing
links is what I talked about a year ago
and and so I'm going to show you a lot
of goodies inside this book and it makes
a wonderful Christmas present
but now the story about Pi in the art of
computer programming in it and it begins
with a book that Martin Gardner
published in the 60s
maybe about the same time as the art of
computer programming first came out any
call the numerology of dr. matrix it
collects a lot of columns that Martin
described by the interviews with this
remarkable I J matrix who who was the
world's greatest numerologists and on
page 60 of that book we have this this
nice picture of Pi here where you see he
gives the first 32 decimals of pi and
actually the three that come in front of
those decimal and and well I love this
and so I I put it in the art of computer
programming in volume 2 and so dr.
matrix has pointed out for example that
the first repeated two-digit number in
the expansion of pi is 26 and if second
appearance comes in the middle of a
curious repetition pattern there 79
nested inside 32 inside 38 38 oh it's
okay so there it is and and dr. matrix
shows a lot of other things about pi and
then he says pi when correctly
interpreted conveys conveys the entire
history of the human race now that I
think that is you know way you might say
that the main purpose of my life then is
to interpret the digits of pi correctly
what what would be more important to
accomplish it in a lifetime so so now i
a year ago i got the following Christmas
present by to a million debt to a
million digits this has been published
actually for more than 20 years but like
this is the 21st printing or so
like this so yeah folks so here's the
first 10,000 digit and then you know it
goes on and and it has on the back cover
you can see it's our bias it's published
by the dark side communication group and
and they have I mean I cut cut I had to
have a friend help me with the Japanese
it says here you know why in heck did
you did you write this book answer if
you have to ask you're not the right
kind of person that then another thing
in my files somebody sent me this in
1981 this was the first time pi was
calculated to two million decimal you
know that book but 1981 was not so long
ago and it was 2 million at that time
and he had you know there were the
person sent me the birthdays of the
people who who did the calculation so a
couple years went by and it was 1983 and
I got this which is ten thousand story
ten million decimals of pi so this is
all on microfiche let's see if we can
zoom in here
[Music]
yeah we probably can't read it but but
it you know so here I have Wow yeah okay
that's that's pretty good so so here I
have ten minutes okay so the question is
what's the what's the current record and
the current record was set this year we
undo here it was set on uncut on pi day
so so the 14th of March of 2019 the
world record now the number of digits is
31 billion for 30 31 trillion for 15
billion nine twenty six million 535 897
digits and it was obtained what what we
using algorithms by Alexander II I don't
know he might be here and I think he
lives around here and and a mighty well
who led a team at Google and I had the
privilege of meeting Emma last month so
this is the current status other digits
of pi now when I first began as an
assistant professor at Caltech in the
60s every once in a while they would
have strange visitors drop in the
department and the and the secretaries
used to to send them over to my office
and you know and one guy a man came to
ask if anybody had had calculated the
value of pi out to the end yet but you
know thirty one trillion well is that
the end okay so so I tried to explain to
him that it that Pi was proved
irrational but that didn't seem to sink
in so I finally I showed him a listing
of what was it a hundred thousand
decimals and I I told him that it hadn't
ended yet so but I wish at that time I
would have had tech done because now I
can show you PI all the way out to the
end
that's that's all we need to know for
that part okay now how do you remember
all these digits and well I I learned
when I was young see now I now I have a
a rhyme assisting my favorite my feeble
brain it's tasks some time resisting and
so I count the number of letters now I
have a rhyme assisting you know and and
I learned that that there's a better one
it's called let's see what is it yeah oh
I'm sorry how I need a drink alcoholic
of course after the heavy lectures
involving quantum mechanics where you
can you can count the letters you know
she remember that phrase and then you
and then you know what they did this two
pi are these uh Oh for a while but but I
gotta show you this this incredible book
which is which is one of the greatest
achievements of a leap in literature not
awake you know three one four one five
nine two six five three five nine sorry
eight so it a dream embodying pies did
is fully for ten talented but by Mike
Keith in the back it's a play a story
fantasies in modern verse and other
writing
following without exception one of the
textbook math motifs five digits and so
the corresponding complete accuracy
that's all first paragraph is just is
just perfect but in the book he does it
for ten thousand digits so don't hear it
it so on the Left we see the first
several hundred digits of pi at
and and now I fall a tired suburban and
liquid under the tree the idea is to
make it seem as if he didn't have any
constraint when he was writing now of
course pie has has zeros in it and so
what are you gonna do with a word of
length zero no so easy
whenever he has a word of length 10 that
means zero but and when he has a word of
length 11 it means one one angle
probably's one two and so on so so this
is the language he calls pilot and he
wrote this entire book booking in Polish
so so for example you see the first zero
here comes at at digit number 33 and
that will be here about bitterness of
possible fortune so the bitterness is
ten letters long select there's the five
and the zero he's got he's got double
one here and that's eleven eyes of
rationalism you see this is this was
four two one one okay now looking a
little further ahead here's a case where
he got nine nine nine nine nine nine you
know okay so so what does he do with
that well it was beautiful
blameless bloodless guiltless ceaseless
limitless boundless so he you know first
he talks about things he has little
essays in here he has short poems he has
you know epigrams and then okay here's a
dialogue between Bob taking two threads
together but oh yeah a movie so here
you've got
yeah zom peer chronicle and it's a
science fiction story it makes sense and
yet the entire thing you know whenever
whenever Victor comes in that means that
digits of six Gregory comes in it's
seven and so on
voiceover is nine and it all works and
you know it makes sense in the real
tutor for us however is it is a
classroom
hi a phrase and all of these all of the
clues are actually no no this is the
second question the first the first
question puzzle here so narrow cattle
path you know it's six zero Scandinavian
is one two and and and and actually it's
a real crossword puzzle and the it you
know it obeys all the rules of cross the
puzzles for where the black squares
should go and good thing and and the
title is Reverend Spooner upon books
well like it has this theme of Greaves
of laughs here he's got win against fake
I mean these are these are spoonerisms
on books okay in any way so this all you
know another rule is that you ignore
punctuation and numbers the numbers
don't don't come but but but then he
talks about that you know he talks about
it and he talks about the spoonerism
trio being a little difficult and then
he he says as I approached the doors
there's Will Shortz in an undershirt no
I think you know Will Shortz is the
great crossword puzzle editor at New
York Times who okay I say ahem detecting
shorts missing
all right so um you know so there's more
of this and and well I've spent a lot of
time on this but he's also got a perk up
a perfect sonnet in here let's see if I
can find it I think that was page 60
yeah here we go to page 70 so you know
14 lines exactly the right kind of a
masculine feminine rhymes that get and
so on
so my keith tribute to pi know now just
kind of served as an inspiration as i
write the art of computer programming as
you see so no i in the art of computer
programming of course it occurs in its
normal meaning as the ratio of the
circumference to diameter of the circle
and and spent for example here's apart
from the beginning of valley one we're
talking about Sterling's approximation
to factorials and so here we have the
fact that pi occurs in this rather weird
way that was one of my that was actually
one of my computer news that was in the
year 2010 I gave up my Christmas lecture
was why pi
hey why does pi occur in the factorial
and it turned out there was a nice way
to understand it you can you can look it
up online if you okay so
altogether I counted today I thought
there were there would be more but it
turned out there were something like
1,700 places where where pie where I
could find that you know backslash P I
followed by a backslash B which is a
word break yeah I just used egress and
and I found a 1,700 places which means
pi occurs maybe once that you know twice
every five pages in the book so far and
well sometimes it only stands for a
permutation or something is not not
actually for the number of pi but most
of those are our first real mathematical
meeting however it often is also used in
order to show that when I ever I need an
example and pi is available like it
shows that I didn't rigged the examples
so so the first time I think I I did
this was in volume 1 on page 397 so it
said what what oriented tree on the
vertices 1 to 10 has a canonical
representation 3 1 4 1 5 9 2 6 5 ok so
of course I didn't explain that this was
PI but the point was that that I was
writing this I thought I you know I
wanted the reader to to try to do some
examples see if they could understand
that the rule in the text and so nice
choice in exercise and here's the answer
to that exercise from the very first
printing of the book which was which was
almost 52 years ago now and so here's an
oriented tree that corresponds to 3 1 4
1 5 9 according to the rule that was
described it in that part of the book
alright so uh well I I have two comments
here one is well those were the days
when we had a lot of space
for the illustrations right now I
wouldn't dare take up three inches of
space for one illustration in the art of
computer programming I think they call
it the real estate I have a very tight
page budget and I work sometimes ten
minutes to save a line but but but the
other thing that jumped out at me when I
looked at this this morning was that
there's a mistake here because I should
have drawn it this was just just I
should have drawn arrows on it there's
supposed to be an oriented tree so it's
all I supposed to have arrows going up
and and for example on the next page I
have another in the answer to another
exercise the exercise was about a
different way to get a correspondence
between digits and and oriented trees
and in this case so you know had this
picture so so somebody noticed that
there were arrows on this side and on
this control in the second edition that
came out in 1973 this was finally
corrected so I kept doing this over and
over then what when I I had a good case
where a good situation where I needed
some number that that was more or less
random I would I would try I would use
pike first if I needed to such numbers I
would probably go to e or for some other
mathematical cost but anyway the point
being that since PI doesn't have any any
reason to be particularly reason to be
unusual then what I'm my example is
pretty typical of what you would find if
you tried anything else that you said
that came up came across something new
that presented to you a new problem
tomorrow so well that happened 18 times
in volume 2 and
it happened five times in buying three
and it happened thirty times in volume
for a now you can how do I know this
well you can look in the index to the
book so if you look in the index or the
book you will see I think I have a
picture of it here this is from volume 4
a so it'll say PI you know a source of
quote random unquote data and then it
gives these 30 references and says see
also Python but ok so then if you look
at those pages you'll see various ways
that that Pi snuck in and I want to show
you now one of the more unusual ones in
volume for a this is on page 98 so your
the beginning of when I needed a random
boolean function of four variables
naturally you described a boolean
function of four variables by giving the
truth table which is a sequence of 16
zeros and one so I took the binary
representation of Pi 1 1 0 0 1 0 0 1 so
ok in fact I have a way to remember that
I can remember PI and octal the
following it said you start out with
saying you can say most people only know
PI and decimal now comes the phrase but
I I know the octonal facts about pi but
I I know the octonal facts about PI but
you but you say no very loud because it
means 0 so
so three one one zero three five five
two and as octal represent eight base
eight and and from that you can get the
base two representation if you okay now
so here's a essentially random function
of four variables and and and so so I
you know the normal thing that people do
with with boolean functions is to try to
put them in to level a form of as a or
of ads and so here's the the shortest
way to represent that function X X 1 bar
and X 2 bar and X 3 bar or something
okay so it takes ten steps to represent
with two level logic this pie function
but on the other hand on page 98 I'm
talking about sneaky ways to calculate
boolean farmers that go beyond two
levels of logic and and allow you to to
use other gates and so here it turns out
with only four gates you can you can
calculate this random function and
that's typical that that most most
function to four variables there's some
sneaky trick that that human beings
would probably not think of that that
actually doesn't I can use the PI
function again on page 205 when I'm
talking about representation of boolean
functions inside of a computer because
the best way to do that is a so-called
BDD one of these Christmas lectures in
the past was a maybe two of them more
about BD DS I know 10 15 years ago
and so here a more or less random
function here's the here's the way we
represented as a in a BDD which means if
x1 is 0 you take the left branch if FX 1
is plus you take the right branch and
then you look at x2 in the second and so
on finally you get to either false or
true and that tells you the value of the
boolean
so this is a one the most important data
structure
I got another use of Pi here that that
probably no nobody recognizes unless
they go to the index and it refers them
to page 382 and then you have to figure
out what on on page 380 - looks like pi
well I put it in yellow here so that you
can that you can see it this is + 0 0 +
+ - + + + - anybody get that so so
there's this what may be the most
wonderful number system of all is the
balanced ternary number system which
would base 3 and the digits are + 0 + -
so here is here is PI in balanced
ternary you see it fit me you know one
time I guess
here's a vision good yeah okay so okay
so so you know the plus means it it's
also the same as saying 1 0 point 0 1 1
and then minus 1 1 1 1 minus 1 0 0 and
so on base 3 so this is you know 1 times
3 plus 0 plus 0 over 3 plus 1 over 9
plus 1 over 9 20 27 minus 1 over 81 and
so on you got the idea
so this is the balanced ternary and and
so it here was a case where I needed
some string of plus zeros in mine and
minuses in order to in order to describe
a elders and and so what better than 2
then to use time let's see where am I
now this is on c3 good so so that's
volume for a and and they say there are
lots of cases there but nah let's go to
volume for B which is the part that you
know that I'm currently working on it
and so so volume for B I began writing I
began writing the the current volume in
the middle you know when you write a
computer program you do the
initialization last so so
a few years ago volume 4 fascicle 6 came
out and this section about
satisfiability and I gave some of my
Christmas lectures about satisfiability
during those years and so this has again
well if you look in the index we should
be able to find pi yep by a source of
random data 1214 so on someone so ok and
the PI function occurs it is - ok so
that's that's what--that's fascicle 6
the middle part the middle third of
volume 4 beat but but but the first
third is what has now you know got me
excited this is the that the galley that
I have here a galley is the same as as a
real book except for two things with it
on the paper is thicker and and the
binding falls apart so I'm going to try
and try to baby this you know but but if
you open if you open this book you've
got to a random page like I guess I
should turn to page 31 or so okay so
anyway you'll probably find I said
something about puzzles because there
are dozens and dozens and dozens of
puzzles described of all different kinds
that I had a ball writing this because
it turns out that the kind of algorithms
I'm describing here are best illustrated
by by using but by their connection with
puzzles and and the emphasis is not in
the book is not on how to solve the
puzzles but how to create the puzzles so
you know I'll just scroll through a few
more pages so you get a little of the
flavor of what's what's here I I'm in
the middle of some an certain exercises
here
and I'll show you more details of some
of these puzzles as we go but anyway
this is the and it also starts out with
with about 25 pages of it's called
mathematical preliminaries redux this
means I wrote the first mathematical
preliminaries section in night in the
60s and a lot of mathematics has been
discovered since then and so and so now
I I need to update that but it starts
out talking about mean fact pi is you
know was using a mathematical sense care
for example in the Cauchy distribution
and things like that okay so now but but
mostly puzzles islets puzzle puzzle
school or and and puzzles of many many
different kinds in each of these each of
these kinds of puzzles has its own
little cult that has developed around it
so I know you know a lot of people have
wasted countless hours working on this
kind of stuff but I like it because I
know so many mathematicians at computer
scientists who they chose their career
essentially because they they got hooked
on puzzles and of course in the index is
a book it'll say PI source of random
data and sure enough there's plenty of
just putting these so I'm going to show
you these got most of the rest of the
talk talk
I'm good I'm going to show you about
these so see I guess I'll start with
page
yeah 72 ok
okay well what what's one of right now
probably the most famous puzzle of all
time is the Roku and I and it turns out
that this is a the dancing links method
that I talked about a year ago is the
killer app for pseudocode just it you
present a silikal problem and you use
dancing links and it just cruises to the
solution it's amazing so I need an
example of absolute to work on it here
it is three one four one five nine two
six five three five eight nine seven
nine okay so I I was able to get thirty
first thirty two digits of pi in there
the other two examples I went I didn't
have time to work it out but but
actually it it's been proved that thank
you you need at least seventeen clues in
it every pseudo cool puzzle and this
this one has only seventeen clues this
one has only sixteen so it doesn't have
a unique solution but this one so so the
question is you know I wanted to give an
example with it with with only seventeen
clues but I had to I had to deviate
after a while after the nine seven eight
then the last two are wrong but if
somebody has time I refer to well the
next page
so so the pie example that I gave you no
example a on the previous page turned
out to be a good way to illustrate that
the reason why dancing links works so
fast on it and so and so there's a chart
here but then afterwards it says now of
course the puzzles aren't always this
easy this one has only 17 clues that
that makes naked singles less likely and
so on it comes from Gordon Royals online
collection of about fifty thousand
seventeen clues pseudo cool now nobody
has a compiled a complete catalog but
but he's a really great graph theorist
and appears to be nearly complete
because for the last 10 years or so
nobody's been able to yoni really does
anybody find one that's not equivalent
to one of when it was on his list so so
if you have time just go through and you
know download these jeans fifty thousand
and and and and look at all the
different permutations of them and and
then look for subsets that it called 3 1
4 and 5 9 2 17 digits and then it also
had a person the 17th that has to be the
17 clues so it's not or the question
that somebody would actually know
whether or not there exists that's a
better example that I could have used
here okay now by the way when I I had a
lot of fun composing this example and I
thought I thought it was an original
idea but I found out a couple years
later that that johan de Ruyter had
already put such a puzzle that's what
oku on his website which had I think
also the 33 digits I'm not sure I don't
remember how much Johan are you here
yeah do you have 32 mm yeah yeah okay so
so it turned out then that that may be
there anyway
there's some views out there calling
people to create to Doku puzzles that
have the clues with three one four one
five nine right and and and and then
when I when I discovered you Hans
website I found that last year on pi day
he he put this amazing puzzle on online
again has the 32 two digits of pi and
this is this call a Japanese arrow
puzzle and and and so the every box
names the exact number of distinct
digits that it points to so for example
three points down so it means all these
what is one two three four five this is
ten by ten so except for three so these
nine boxes there's three distinct digits
in there okay so here's a one of course
that's obvious but here's a one pointing
all the way down so that means that all
of the numbers in this column except
maybe the one at the top are equal so
he's got all of the occlusive pi and it
works out perfectly
I mean there's a unique solution to this
thing so
[Applause]
now I have an open problem in my book
can you go to 33 digits of pi or or 34
now you have a little trouble because
the 33rd digit is a zero and that's why
you can't do it in pseudo ku ku you're
cut 32 is the best you can ever get but
but with this puzzle you could have a
zero because you could have a box at the
edge of the diagram that's pointing off
you know at the right hand side points
to the right I mean it was be point two
zero different things until you so that
would make perfect sense that you can
have zero so maybe some of you will not
get any sleep during the next month but
now in the published book this was rated
number this is right at 40 but I've
changed it to date to 41 because I
figured it's a little harder than a 40
level exercise and besides 41 is of
course right there in PI here the book
that I did I found - this is a
publishing the Netherlands a couple
years ago and look at the cover here's a
pseudo GU that has three one four one
five nine around a circle and well he
they had to in order to accomplish this
they had to add another constraint and
that is on each diagonal you need all
the numbers 1 to 9 so so this particular
pattern it has I don't know 3000
solutions if you don't if you only use
the normal rules of pseudocode but if
you insist that the that the dista it'll
be one to nine and then it goes down to
eight solutions then you insisted this
tonight dying also one a9 then it's a
unique solution okay so a beautiful
construction again that same Muse was
over
here's a proof that it can be done now
I'm on page okay back to classical five
nothing let's go to take the page 476
you're here we get to a very nice very
cold well I like to call jigsaw Sudoku
there's other names of geometric Sudoku
Pollock polyomino Seussical squealy
sodoku thing but here's here's my my
example of a jigsaw Sudoku so instead of
still have the rule that every row
supposed to have 1 to 9 every column 1 a
9 but but then there's these these
regions the boxes aren't necessarily 3x3
boxes but but you have arbitrary shaped
regions and so it was it was possible to
get a very nice puzzle jigsaw puzzle
using PI as they as the clues and and
and I was helped with Bob by Bob Harris
who was the the Grandmaster this kind of
thing in fact he he wrote he found this
this example which inspired though the
whole thing here says Martin Gardner and
it's a jigsaw suit ago and and it uses
only the 9 letters G R a and D T IME
and of course it has a unique solution
and when I saw that I was inspired to
for my Christmas card ten years ago what
was to make this which the Christmas
star rises and again has a unique
solution okay so I try to expect I try
to give tools in the book that you can
be used as a help to this but I but you
know but I don't think machine learning
is going to be able do this in the near
future
on on page 128 I said some of you might
know that New York Times pseudo coupe
New York Times have an extra extra
feature that they give you for extra 3x3
boxes and you're supposed to and those
are supposed to become perfect one two
three four five and seventy nine as well
and that's and so it's called high
pursuit of cool and and so here's an
example I was lucky and I could I could
get high person's again you don't need
as many clues in high personally so I
could know follow the digits of pi and
make it the point is that we have a
situation where there are zillions and
zillions of great sets of numbers that
that in this case satisfy they did this
to suit local constraints the high
personal constraint and and so there's
so many many of them you you can expect
that that we can put extra constraints
on you know okay don't just make a
puzzle make a puzzle that does something
extra something unusual and and despise
one of the natural unusual things to
subscribe for and in cases like this
okay the next one is even more fun night
and Bishop sugoku
so here this was invented by David NASA
new resident has a new book along the
subject published by the AMS recently so
let's take let's take a look at this
diagram for example zoom way in on this
yeah good okay so here you see every
every row contains three nights you have
to look that's a chest night and and
every column contains three nights and
every 3x3 box contains three nights okay
so this is twenty seven nights arranged
on it on a nine by nine board and in
each one I wrote how many other nights
are being attacked by it okay so like
like this guy has a 3 in it that's four
one two three okay this has a two so
it's this one and this one okay
there's a zero here this guy okay that's
a configuration with three nights in
every rule column box and and and I know
how many are attacking okay so now let's
remove some of these clues and we just
go to this this is enough to reconstruct
what was on the left okay and what the
clues three one four one five now a nine
a night can only attack eight eight
other cells so like six oh there's no
way I could put a nine in here right and
if I had only three one four one five
that wouldn't be enough clues to do it
so I just made three three three okay so
there it is that's not and and that it
is nice to look okay similarly there's
bishops no clue and so here three one
four one five nine two six I this a
bishop can attack
and other bishops okay so so lots of fun
there
my question is what about what night I
forgot to wear my hearing aid can
somebody else so go back Don go back to
the yeah and look at those three threes
there yep okay three threes what about
it
so each each one has to be attacked by
three others and so you could go here
this one is attacked by by this one this
one this one with what's three plus
three in sorry you don't go forward and
I have a theme in this well there's a
lot more than instance we don't go but I
didn't really have a way to put pie into
a lot of the puzzles that are related to
things like polyominoes and stuff in
here however here's one so in in a
jigsaw Sudoku the regions have nine
cells and so that's
polyomino with not me it's called a non
amin oh and and so if you study dominoes
so you can say that a it is small if it
give it fits it into a compact square
and it's slim if it doesn't have any any
two by two
any fat inside of it and and so there's
an exercise that that says you know how
many nominals are both small and slim
and then it says oh but how can you take
nine of those and put them into a into a
nine by nine box so that we'd have a
jigsaw pseudocode and so then it and
then the question is okay he that and
then design a puzzle pipe that I use it
disappears and here's the answer to that
exercise or one of the answers because
it B says there are 16 solutions to Part
B and so I saw you know I did this for
one of them and I give the reader that
the fun of trying to do it on anybody
here get the Guardian okay so so in
Guardian I doesn't have sort of know I
guess that's absolute ago but it also
has something called furoshiki and and a
foolish iki puzzle is a 5x5 array where
you're forced to put in numbers 1 2 5 he
each each row and each column gets the
numbers 1 2 5 but then it'll have it'll
have everyone so well the less that you
see there's less than sign here so it
says that whatever you put it here has
to be less than that guy okay and and
you know sometimes it'll you know the
less time sign is it is rotated so this
turns out to be a kind of a pleasant
pastime also and it's it it was carried
over when the Guardian switched over to
their new their new magazine format so 3
1 4 1 5 great so I actually I want to
give the reader a chance to exercise and
have the fun of making up such close
to exercise the next page says inspired
by this what previous one construct a
nine by nine foolish et who diagonal
contains three one four one five nine
two six five in that order every other
clue should be a less than sign not a
greater than not a vertical or
horizontal version of it and so that is
and it turned out that there was a kind
of a pleasant thing to discover and and
if we zoom we're not areas you've seen
so many less than signs occasionally in
the e of course you try to have a fewer
few left and sciences but as it's needed
to make the things so you start out with
all all nine by nine Latin School Latin
squares that have the Procrit diagonal
and you try to narrow it down by until
you get down to a unique solution
so that's furoshiki another one based on
five but on Latin squares is called
KenKen and in here they they have cages
regions called cages in which you you
give a number and then you and you give
up a mathematical operation so the
operation is plus minus times or divide
if it's plus it means add together all
the numbers if it's dies multiply
together but if it's - it has to be only
a size two and in the case of a minus
then need to take the difference of the
two numbers and and similarly with if
it's a division it has to be of the
reagent has cage has to be size two and
and you divide one number by the other
so here's an example where you you know
the where you get a two after dividing
one one number by another and if your
that's gotta be there too over over 1 or
4 over 2 because your numbers the only
one two three four five okay so this is
Ken Ken and you see the clues here are
three fourteen fifteen nine two six five
it's boring right but it's actually kind
of fun to make up these these examples
and and so and so I asked can you make a
tip with nine by nine Ken Ken that has
as many digits of pi as possible and I
got and I you know I I had to finally
leave pi after a while but this is as
far as I got so I got three one four one
five nine two six oh I ain't no five
three five eight nine seven nine three
two one three four but then the last one
I blew it so so by the time I had here
we still had more than one solution to
the public to the puzzle and
surprisingly saying that the product of
these five numbers is 3780
actually effects roll one of the
solution but but I I sweat blood over
this one actually before it but but but
maybe somebody can come up with a more
perfect one but there were times when I
thought that's ken ken another one of
course pseudo go got so popular any
anything that's had a Japanese name sort
of became a bit of a craze - so there's
Kaku roll and actually the guru
puzzles have been have been around under
under other name and cross some puzzle
and since the since the 30s but kokoro
is where the different rocks it's like a
crossword puzzle but the nut but instead
of using letters you use numbers and
then it tells you these the some of the
numbers but the rule is that the words
in the solution they have to contain
distinct digits
so get in one row you can use the same
digit several time but but it in one
word you can only use it once okay so so
here was a example of kuru where I gave
where the exercise is you know to use a
computer to help you design a world that
for which the answer not the statement
of the puzzle but but the answer to the
puzzle is PI so here's the solution to
that puzzle 31 41 59 okay so I
prescribed the the top row and you're
supposed to figure out some other clues
for which force that to be the solution
now there are several other kind of
puzzles - not based on Latin squares not
based on I'm this kind of digits and and
and what one of the one of the best is
called G dot o H I and that sounds
Japanese - but it's actually comes from
Israel and so but it's a pretty
different idea here we're given the
numbers and and we're supposed to fill
in so that we get the numbers in this
case 1 - 16 that that form a path of a
king on the chess board a king covers
all 16 squares and and it's and it
starts at 1 that's going to have to go
here for two and then three and four is
gonna have to be one of these two
because it has to get to five here and
then you know somehow up to 14 and then
15 to 16 the way the way a king moves
from one square to square of diagonally
or not and so here's a it's worked out
the solution here's the eight here's the
answer so exercise can you make a hit
dot two at that's ten by ten
like that uses two digits of pi as the
clues all right now
that's it so a 10 by 10 means that we
have one included numbers and and
remember at the very beginning I showed
you how if you looked at the digit of pi
there were these repeats that there was
this 26 26 and thing it came along and
so well that as I was preparing this
lecture it occurred to me
another puzzle I had never thought of
before how how far can you go break chop
and pie up into one and two-digit groups
without without making a repeat so you
know I don't want the 26 to right so
have to break I have to break this 26
ups but I can use 92 here until toast
so if I'm gonna have a puzzle that that
uses distinct one and two-digit Clues
wonder how far I could go when the
answer was that I could get up to 81
digits of pi
before I was stuck and there are 16 ways
to do it but anyway this is one of the
examples 314 and 1592 and so on and but
but but after this you know I'm out of
luck because I already use the nine
somewhere up here and and the 898 I mean
the eight is already used and so is 86
is over over here somewhere not easy so
so I'm stuck at this point but but for
this hey doctor you're gonna have to
find something well it's turned out that
that there is a way to get pretty far
into PI so 31 41 and so on up to got the
84 here and turned out that this this
was probably the hardest one again I
thought it was going to be impossible
but then I showed it to my friend in in
Bulgaria and
he was able to solve it by hand I don't
know if anybody else who was able to do
that but it's really it's really
fiendishly difficult puzzle but also
satisfying to me that that this was
enough information to force the king
path that there's no other way to do
there's only one way to you know have to
beat the king was there after 31 steps
and that and it has to get over here and
forth but by step 41 which means it has
to you know waste time somehow
but now to conclude I some of the
besides these numerical kind of puzzles
Nicoli in Japan had come out with lots
of reading really great puzzles that
don't use numbers at all but they own
but but they don't like like massan
which you only uses what white dots and
black dots as if you as if you have
stones on it on a goal board and they
also have what has one that uses not
numbers numbers but in a different way
and that's called smoother link so
slither link puzzle looks like this you
have you have a grid of dots here and
and that means every once while you put
in a number and and that number is the
number of edges the goal is to create a
path around the dots a single loop path
and and and if there's a three here that
path has to use three edges of the
around that square if it's a two it has
to be two of the edges and if it's you
know zero it means it better not touch
the square so that's just that's a
splitting link puzzle and I gave this
but the convention is when you give the
clues it's nice to have them if there's
a clue in this corner then you'd have
the corresponding clue in this corner so
here it is
example sizzling puzzle and and it says
what surprise is concealed in the
following puzzles so you ask yourself
the puzzle and here's this here's the
answer yeah okay you're just doing that
cuz you want me to wrap it up but but
like I said Matthew is another great
thing which is based on stuff so here
the question is now find a way that each
of these has to be either a white stone
or a black stone and and the result
should be a valid matthew puzzle has
only one solution and and that turned
out to be a real fun thing too so here's
here's the book that I think it is it
tons of fun
and it also by the way it teaches a few
algorithms on the side
[Applause]